hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are back at the 1857 first
American chess congress with the
candidates tournament of 2020 being put
on hold until further notice we are
continuing with our Morphy saga and well
whatever else happens in the chess world
like I said so here we we stopped at
Game two between a lupus and and poor
Charles Murphy Murphy won Game one
fairly easily and it's it's quite the
game so I'm sure you're gonna enjoy it
without further ado let's check it out
and if you are just joining us in the
saga as Paul Morphy is a pretty big deal
in the chess world I will put a link in
the description below it will be in the
description below in every Morphy video
so you can start the saga from the
beginning if you want to catch up yeah
which I do recommend you do but getting
back to this game post and now after
losing Game one opens with E for and
it's important to mention that after
game one finished game two started the
same day they started this game at 7:30
p.m. and then they play again till
midnight and then at midnight we have an
adjournment until tomorrow
but okay efore more free replies wood e5
Knight f3 knight c6 and Bishop to b5 so
the rule opus is on the board we ignite
to have six more figures for the the
Berlin defense and now castles by by
Polson we have Knight captures on e4 by
by Murphy the Rio gambit we have d4 and
now a six somewhat rare removed in
nowadays but it is still played and
Bishop back to d3 now today a bishop to
a4 Bishop captures and c6 are or are
almost exclusively played but in those
days had Bishop back to D 3 by Paulsen
and now d5 strengthening his knight on
e4 we at night capture Sonny for on e5
by Paulsen and now Knight captures on d4
and it is as of this move that this
position has never been reached again so
continuing the game we have looked the
a1 now putting pressure on the night
here and here more if we just plays
Bishop to e6 now do you see more fees
sneaky idea why the bishop should not
capture Knight why you can't win a
pawn here it's actually it's actually
very tricky because after Bishop
captures pawn caspere's and rook
captures now do you see more face idea I
even pause the video if you don't so for
those of you who were able to do that
congratulations and spotting the
nastiest the nastiest of discoveries and
for those who if you just want to enjoy
the show it's nice to be 3 with an
attack on the rook and also the Queen
now the point is if you just trade
Queens then you have the threat of
checkmate and also just of losing the
rook on a1 so rook the rook to d1 rook
e1 locks rook captures here will be made
so here there's nothing to do once you
prevent checkmate just not a knight
characters here
that's not a knight Knight captures rook
and this game over so what you would
have to do after rook captures on e4 and
this Knight to b3 idea is actually Queen
to h5 now saying if you capture the rook
I have Knight captures on f7 and you
will not be able to capture it because
of all the pins here so here we would
have g6 Knight captures and g 6h captors
and g6 and the rook captures on e6 of
course with with optimal play characters
captures with check King d7 and now you
grab the night as there is no more
threat of checkmate since the King is
blocking the Queen and now we have this
position where Morphy is more fees up
the exchange but his King is somewhat
loose and he's also down to pawn so it
would be would be a trade off but if
more if you can get to the King to
safety here maybe get this rook into the
game should be should be alright but of
course that's easier said than said and
done this is basically more of his idea
behind giving the pawn here so Paulsen
declines it keep he go c3 Knight back to
c6 we have captures captures and now
just Queen to a for putting pressure on
the pawn here we have Queen to d7 and
only now Paulsen grabs the pond while
the Queen guards the d1 square captures
captures and the rook sorry not rogue
captures but instead the Queen captures
even better the rook now guards the d1
square and we have this position where
it's again a trade of morpheus pawn
structure here on the Queen side is
somewhat ruin however he does have the
bishops pair which more fee more fee
relaxes bishop pair so bishop the DC
continuing development and night 2d - we
have castles by morphe and now Knight to
f3 and here brush up to d5 and here
morphe is extremely happy both of his
bishops eyeing the the white king we
have Queen back the d3 and now rook 88
or hoping hope hoping for characters
capture so the other route can can come
to e8 Bishop to g5 by Paulson again he
wants to connect rooks and now Queen the
g4 by Murphy with h3 pushing the Queen
back here there's the simple threat of
just captures and f3 and then you've
removed the defender of the bishop so
you just pick it up
so here h3 kicking the Queen away Queen
to h5 and now Bishop back to d2 to parry
all the threats and now rook the e6 more
if he goes for a nice roof lift with the
idea of either doubling here or even
just shifting the rook into the attack
problem is if you capture and captures
it then morph it gets the semi-open F
file for its rook and this pawn will
start marching forward so it will be it
will be a good position for black here
however Paulsen could have seized the CD
initiative so to say with c4 it's it's a
nice move now that the route blocks the
e6 square and here we would see a trade
as it's unavoidable capture scatterers
characters in G captures and we get to
this position with equal material on the
board position pawn structure pretty
much identical with more of you having
ruined the pawn structure on the Queen
side and Paulsen having a ruin form
structure on the King side here as you
can see how but it would be equal if
game so after look the e6 Paulsen
instead of the c-4 mu he went for Knight
to g5 he wants to kick away the rook but
this kind of only helps Morphy get his
rook into the game because morphe
actually wanted to switch it over to g6
and now Knight to e4 back now here again
you could you could also force matters
with c4 and basically just offer a pawn
here after a bishop capture screen
captures an h6 but then you play see
five and you get you you get a lot of
contra play for example the bishop
cannot go back you have to capture then
rook a c1 and you have a lot of
weaknesses here for the white rook to
gobble up and of course you have to give
up at least it
tonight here but you already want a
piece so it's not a problem so that's
one way to go about it again this c4
move basically presents itself but
Paulson goes back Knight to e4 blocking
of course rook rook characters and g2 or
does it more feet or goes exactly for
this rook captures and G - he wants to
exploit this pin and wind went back the
material with f5 so King captures and g2
and now f5 and here of course well you
will grab back your your material but
morphe does have the bishop pair and he
doesn't mind even of the exchange this
rook on a want isn't really doing all
that much
so here Paulsen played f3 to
strengthening the position a little bit
and now feel free to pause the video
what would you play here in this
position well I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it there is only one good
move here for morphe and that is f
captures on e4 it's it's an odd move to
play especially when someone asks you to
solve a position just to capture a piece
but in this position it's actually the
way to go
so f captures any four wins the game
however black white decides to play it
for example I've capture us on e4 now
you go Queen to g6 with Czech and after
the King moves doesn't really matter
what you play rook F - and you are very
quickly getting checkmated not not much
you can do about this on the other hand
or and of course if Ruby g1 just blocks
then Brooke - H - is mate there's also
that in the position so what you would
have to do after F captors on e4 is
maybe give back some material with rook
captures and g4 but still Queen g6 check
and now Ruby g4 is impossible because
you pick up the Queen on d3 so again
after working - h1 Queen g3 threatening
mate and now after the mate is prevent
to let's say Queen here now you go for
rook captures on f3 so what here Queen G
- and now comes the the trigger the
trickery rook F 1 check of course if you
capture with the Queen then Queen - H 2
is mate so we'd have to capture with the
rook but now Bishop captures on e4 and
there is nothing to be done here Queen
has the capture and rook to Queen th -
is mate so with this F captors on e4
more
he wins the game however Morphy switched
the move order more fee instead of
capturing and then queen g6 first played
Queen to g6 check and this allows pulse
and the incredible save with Knights the
g5 and it's not a problem or if he wins
back the piece but now it's not as as
potent of a position as it was so here
h6 was played on morphine
but now c4 and now what do you do here
Bishop back to f7 and now comes h4 just
strengthening the position and the rook
to b8 by morphe nut in russia to win
back the piece as it is inevitable
so Queen to c2 getting out of the nasty
discoveries and now comes H captures and
g5 with H captors and g5 and Bishop to
e6 now we've worked the h1 by Paulsen
with the idea of probably doing
something along the H file maybe maybe
double rooks or something like that
without that Queen move but there were
better ways to go about the position but
okay Bishop to e7 by morphe immediately
goes after the g5 pawn who wants to bust
open the position in front of the White
King but now F for strengthening g5 and
now c5 morphe needs to get hold of the
White King he wants to play Bishop the
c8 the b7 and grab hold of this diagonal
this way so rook 81 now saying that if
you just move the bishop then I can pick
up your Bishop on e7 so King f7
defending and the now rook to h3 with
ideas of doubling up on the H file but
also with the option of just going
rookie 3 or rook d3 depending on what
more if he plays more if it continues
with Bishop to c8 and now it's very
useful that the rook moves so you don't
have to worry about in any material
winnings here King the g1 getting out of
the light squares and Bishop the b7 and
okay now morph is a bishop is extremely
strong here there should be back to c1
now the Queen can also enter the game
and rook to d4
just trying something here you might you
might be able to squeeze in Queen to c6
but still it's hard to do anything along
the die the darks the lights worse as
the Queen and rook are covering both g2
and h1 but it's useful to have
as a resource we have b3 just
strengthening the pond here and now rush
up to d6 again more if he goes after the
pond now Queen e2 saying okay if you go
after the pond here then Queen th check
will be all that I need as it will be
checkmate
so rook to e4 blocking Queen to F - and
now Queen to east six if you repeat the
rook to d4 then Queen can come up to h2
and then you can just start kicking away
Bishop to e3 will kick away the rook and
it's hard to say where where the rook
will go from there you have ideas like
rook to h8 maybe this ro can come here
and it could be could be very unpleasant
so after Queen to f2 we have Queen to
Easton's by Murphy threatening now to
capture the rook and now Paulsen goes
rook h2 III Morphy again reluctant to do
any trades goes Queen to d7 now maybe he
can get Queen to c6 in and deliver some
queen to h1 checkmate but Queen to h4
now going for Queen to h5 check more fee
blocks at King to g6 and now Queen back
to h3 all of the time keeping an eye on
these two squares we have Bishop back to
e7 and now the Queen also has access
throughout the D file and rook captures
on e4 finally we have Bishop captures on
e4 and now comes Queen to e3 point is
you don't have rope here with Czech
picking up the Queen because after the
rook the rook captures you of course do
not capture right away first you go
Queen to d1 check and now after king of
- now you capture and now is well it's a
bit of a different story
white is still better but it's much less
than you've had so after this Bishop the
e4 capture we have Queen back the e3 and
now Queen to d8 again Morphy trying to
trying to wiggle his way somehow into
the position but it is still very hard
you first have to get rid of this Bishop
away from the e-file so maybe at some
point you can move this Bishop and then
somehow I don't know grab hold of this
diagonal that's pretty much the only
thing more he has going for him also
Queen to h8 fall by Queen - h1 is a
possibility so Queen to h3 stopping that
and now Queen to d4 with
check we have the shifter III and now
Quintus III so morphe was able to wiggle
his way in with the Queen we have Queen
back the f1 and now Queen to a5 saying
that okay I have to try something I'm
pretty I'm looking pretty bad here we
have to try everything we have we have
Queen to f2 defending the a to pawn and
now Queen to b6 again now with the idea
that maybe the bishop can go back and
the Queen can go in front of the bishop
but rookie to now defends the pawn and
the Queen to c6 now saying that we don't
have time for any for any switching for
example if Bishop to a8 well you don't
really have all that much to worry about
you can just go Bishop the d2 or Queen
to h2 and you will again be covering all
the squares so it's still not the moment
so for the moment Queen the c6 by morphe
and now push it back to c1 again
the rope is very strong and the e-file
and the Queen to d7 now we have worked
the detail pushing the Queen back and
now Queen to east six again maybe with
ideas of now bringing the bishop back
but Quinta III not allowing it by
Paulson so Paulson is better but he
doesn't really know how to how to work
the position we have Queen back to c6 by
morphe and the bishop to beat you now
okay finally now his bishop also assumes
the this beautiful diagonal King to f7
and and now that the King defends the
bishop this bishop can now again move
Queen back to h3
now again going for this checking idea
but Queen to g6 preventing it we've
worked h2 now with hopes of trading
Queens and going into an endgame but now
Queen to d6 by morphe and it was in fact
in this position on move 53 that the
players agreed to a draw and as the
title suggests the game lasted for 15
hours so after Game one they started
playing at 7:30 p.m. they adjourned the
game at midnight and then they continued
the other day and then the other day
after after dinner they again continued
playing at 7:30 until midnight
and then the day after tomorrow they
concluded the game but all in all 15
hours of play and really just really
just crazy as
here Paulsen is reluctant to go into
Queen to h5 just to show why why the
game is a draw
it's not a draw but what the why Paulsen
thought it was a draw for example g6
Queen to h7 check King to e8 and now
okay Queen to H a check you're gonna go
King to d7 and now you do have to worry
about Queen to d1 check so first Queen
back to c3 and now this doesn't really
do anything as the king is very safe on
f2 suit have to capture on f4 and then
allow this trade but after characters
characters and characters came to e6 it
would be would be a a draw draw draw an
endgame as more fee is up more fees up
as you can see two points
well one point for a moment but he will
capture this pawn fairly quickly even if
something like this let's say you can go
for this and all in all it will be a
draw yes you have a look against the
bishop but two connected pass pawns are
incredibly strong and chances are
against more if you might even lose this
how you should in fact treat the
position after Queen to d6 where the
draw was agreed upon is not Queen to h5
but Queen back to e3 you have to admit
that your rook h2 Queen h3 idea and the
H file wasn't all that impressive
and now after Queen to d1 check play the
brave King to have to and claim that ok
now you're better because now whatever
you play it doesn't really matter let's
say King g8 now Queen - E - you offer a
queen trade and after the Queen moves
now you go Bishop to e5 let's say you
kick the Queen even further Queen g6 and
now Queen e3 and now you can consider a
move like Queen to h3 going for a trait
and so on while your pieces are on
optimal squares so this is definitely
how you would seek advantage in this
position but Paulsen couldn't work it
out and in the end they decided to draw
this game he was he was afraid of Queen
to d1 a bit too much and he couldn't
find a way to enter the position and
also I would I would just like to
include to this game
a letter from Daniel Willard Fisk the
the professor George Allen about this
game and this matchup in general between
Paulsen and morphine here Willard Fisk
says
nothing can be more pleasing it's from
the book by David David Lawson that I'm
using to prepare for the morphe saga he
says nothing can be more pleasing or
graceful than the elegance of Murphy's
play his manner of touching the pieces
and moving them and so forth I have
never seen him impatient but once in his
second game with Paulson after the
German had taken repeatedly 30 45 and 50
minutes and in some instances over one
hour for only one move Murphy became so
thoroughly worn out that in his haste he
made what should have been his second
move first and was only able to draw a
one-game a splendid piece of chess that
it had been up to that moment he was so
depressed that he was so depressed at
the failure to score so fine a game that
he and I will not finish the sentence
because I was spoiled too much but
basically our Willard Fisk is talking
about this moment where after f3 Murphy
didn't capture the piece and just won
the game with Queen g6 but he reversed
the move order yes he says due to
Paulson's long thinking for over for an
hour for one more 50 minutes for one
move like you know like like very shook
time but yeah definitely took its toll
on Murphy and Murphy I switch the move
order which is something that really
doesn't doesn't happen to took to
Goodall Murphy but here it did and you
know it's no wonder day that they had to
invent chess clocks when such things
happened but yeah Paulson and grabs a
draw against Murphy and the match
continues and so will our sentence that
we have so really abrupted but yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank a lot of Sir Roger
Billings Lucien accordion au coeur du
neon Oh David Kiser and technology and
Isaac Garcon for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous video Ciaran thank you for
watching and I will see soon continuing
the Paul Morphy saga checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world which at this
moment isn't all that much but you never
know so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day